so anyway the topic of my talk is
Internet of Things Python in machine
learning from chips and bits to data
science so you can take you all away
from the hardware level up to data
science and he said I'm Jeff Fisher I'm
an independent consultant based out of
Sunnyvale California okay so this talk
is about an end-to-end project I did and
we won't be predicting the stock market
will just be predicting what your life
would be like on in your house if you
had been home when you're not home so
we'll talk about that so I'll give you
an overview of the project then I'm
going to work you from talked about the
hardware we did and a little bit about
hardware then go through the phases data
capture analysis and then playing the
lights at the end some parting thoughts
if we have time I'll do a little demo I
have a one of these boards here so I can
do a live demo maybe if not you can find
me after to talk if you're interested ok
so before I start on that question is
why Python for the Internet of Things
because when I think of Internet of
Things be kind of before I started this
I thought of C programming and embedded
systems and not really high-level
languages like Python so we certainly
would like to use Python because it's
high-level easy to prototype easy to
explore ideas if you have some hardware
hooked up to your thing some sensor and
you want to do bit twiddling it's nice
to be able to use the Python we develop
print loop repple to do that so it's
certainly a nice language for exploring
and doing things but Python actually
runs on embedded devices depending on
your your definition of embedded device
so the Raspberry Pi you know we started
as a project for kids to use as a as a
personal computer but it has all the if
you can look at so it has all these um
all these I Oh ports here did these
things are io interconnections called
GPIO or general purpose i/o so you can
hook all kinds of sensors and actuators
up to your Raspberry Pi and the
Raspberry Pi can is really a Linux
workstation you can run kind of the full
data science stack pretty much on a
Raspberry Pi so you can run
up mat you can run pandas you can run
numpy you can run scikit-learn all on
your Raspberry Pi it may not be as fast
as like a desktop or server but it'll
still run there so this is great you can
take anything you were doing a normal
Python and run it there and you have
access to all these sensors and things
and so there's lots of projects that
have been done in there's huge hobbyist
community around Internet of Things on
Raspberry Pi at the and it's even been
used in industrial contexts as well so
you can get industrial versions of this
and do the same thing the only downside
is it's not battery friendly so if you
want to do something where you want to
do some remote sensing let's say you're
in a field somewhere and you want to
send some data of some sort coming from
sensors temperature light whatever
you're probably going to need a car
battery to power this thing you're not
going to be powering it off of a couple
double-a batteries so so that's a
challenge but for a lot of applications
you know you're doing in your house it's
still very very usable for that so
another thing we can do is there are
smaller chips so like this esp8266
that's a mouthful but it's a it's a chip
that has it was originally designed to
be used as a Wi-Fi modem it has a CPU
and it has a Wi-Fi radio and has a bunch
of i/o ports so it's great for kind of
doing IOT things it has low power
consumption it's easily a twentieth of
what you would get on a Raspberry Pi and
you can get it lower like playing games
with putting it into various sleep modes
so this is great now that it has a
downside to which is you only have 96k
of memory and that's not gigabytes
that's not megabytes that's kilobytes of
memory that's not a lot of memory you're
not running your Linux there you're not
writing your your side PI on there
you're not running C Python on there
right so you're not going to be doing a
whole lot on this machine luckily
there's something called micro Python
and this is a implementation of Python 3
for embedded devices and micro Python
uses a lot less memory and it runs
directly on the hardware without an
operating system and it even has its own
little file system that runs on the
flash but it's very lightweight and it's
been ported to a number of embedded
devices including the esp8266 and the
other thing I should mention about the
esp8266 is that it's cheap so this
particular board it's a kind of fancy
one I got it from Adafruit and it was
about sixteen dollars but there was in
the the Lua programming language
community they were interested in this
kind of thing so they developed a spec
and there's been a lot of
implementations of it and you can buy
some of these called it's called note
MCU you can buy them on Amazon for about
$8 if you're willing to wait for
shipping from China you can buy them
from China directly for about $4 each
and sometimes even as low as 350 so
they're really cheap you if you screw up
something it's not a problem because it
just pull out another one so anyway
that's what I will use we're going to
use both of these in this project and
finally I just mentioned you know Python
has a great data analysis ecosystem
that's what the old conference is about
and being able to kind of write your
event processing code in the same
language that you do your data analysis
and is very very helpful and in makes it
a lot simpler process okay so motivation
for the project first I thought about
doing a smart thermostat and controlling
my air conditioner and heater but then I
thought maybe that's too dangerous I
don't know for my first IOT project I
want to be you know having a major
repair bill or dealing with high
voltages so I thought lighting is safe
so I can't you know hurt anyone was
lighting hopefully so then what do I do
so the idea and this is actually my wife
suggested originally I don't know how
well that picture shows up but if you're
out of town for the weekend like I am
because I live in Sunnyvale you don't
want to leave your house dark right you
know it just kind of invites people is
it advertisement to people who might
want to break in and take your
electronics and even if that wouldn't
happen is kind of for a peace of mind
you want to make it look like before
they're and so we want it to look more
like this maybe not all the lights on
all the time we'd like to
going to go on and off like people were
in the house and so you can get timers
you can buy you know at Home Depot or
whatever and you plug your light into it
it has a couple buttons you push and if
you can't figure out how to program it
hopefully you programmed it look right
and you're always fooling with that
right before you leave it's kind of
annoying and they're predictable they go
on at 8:00 p.m. they turn off at 10:00
p.m.
someone watching or else more than one
night will see that it's on a timer or
they just look I went on an APM not
eighty to one right and we'll see that
kind of real usage of a house is a lot
less predictable so I when something
that's going to replay the lights that
make it look like someone's there and
it's kind of much more random and I want
a self-contained solution I don't want
to involve third party equipment that
someone could could brick when they go
out of business or get bought by a big
company and I don't want to involve the
cloud because that's a security risk and
a point of failure right so when it be
all self-contained and wouldn't be cool
to use machine learning alright so okay
so here's the application I came up with
the first part of it is the data capture
and this is really a phase of the
project so first I put light sensors
around the house the remote nodes are
using these esp8266 --is the net my
server is the Raspberry Pi and so that's
that's hooked into that my network and
so for for six weeks and was in a
continue taking kid was not in
continuous six weeks but over about six
weeks I captured data from light sensors
in my house so that I knew what when
people were home with the usual patterns
were so then the second phase is I take
that data and I do an offline analysis
and I do all in a to per notebook and so
it's really convenient using all data
science stack and kind of understanding
what the data what are the patterns and
then I want to come up with a machine
learning model that I can use for the
player so the last part is a player and
when you go production then that's all
you need and you know I don't want to
fool with wiring so they have these nice
smart lights and what you do is you just
plot you just wire them put them in your
existing light sockets and and then
there's a there's a REST API you can
call and control the lights
so that's the that's the whole system
and like I said all you really need when
you're kind of in production is a player
so now let me talk about the hardware so
this is what one of the esp8266 boards
looks like you see in the back this
white thing is a breadboard that makes
it easy to plug in different components
that have some connections on the back
and so you don't have to do any
soldering and it's good if you don't
want to full of soldering as well as if
you want to play around and change
things you know you want to add new
things to your board or whatever or we
use it reuse the parts for other things
when you see there's kind of two circuit
boards on this those are called breakout
boards and the reason we have breakout
boards is in the old days kind of when I
started as electronics hobbyist they had
these things called dual inline packages
if you open up an apple two you see
those chips those were easy to work with
but now they have surface mount
technology which are all those flat
chips and as as a normal human that has
big fingers those are really hard to
work with they're designed for printed
circuit boards so some of these
companies like Adafruit and Sparkfun
they've created these breakout boards
which incorporate a number of these
surface mount things and they provide
easy pins on the bottom that you can
hook wires up to and things so that's
what I used so the one I guess on your
left is the light sensor and so that has
a light sensor chip and some support
circuitry and will generate a digital
signal that that can be read by the is
the server board so the processor board
as in USB 80 266 as well as an adapter
to talk to USB and a battery adapter so
you can power the board through the USB
or you can power it from the battery and
you can charge it in the USB also has a
serial port so that I know if you saw
this flowing with it before the talk but
and maybe I'll demo it afterward
but you can basically get the Python
repple that's on this board in your
terminal on your laptop so pretty easy
to do and this is the circuits this is
all the connections logically that I
have
um so you see at the bottom there I
basically the power is being coming is
coming from the the processor board of
the esp8266 board and that's providing
power to the light sensor board and then
there's a a digital circuit protocol
called I squared C which is used for
connecting various peripheral chips and
the light sensor board is using that and
and there's a there's also a support for
that on the esp8266 and an API for two
micro Python so all I have to do is hook
up two wires the SDA is the data it's
basically passing one bit at a time in
serial fashion and SEL is a clock signal
so if you hook up these four wires and
just about anyone can do this then you
have the sensor board so the Raspberry
Pi I've I've taken those those pins and
I'm using this adapter to put it out to
the breadboard so I can easily get to
things and you see I have the same light
sensor board and for fun I hooked up an
LED so I could turn it on and off from
Linux and the circuitry is pretty much
the same I've got I've got the light
sensor I've got the same connections
basically in passing power and I'm
providing the data connections so the
hardware not that hard even if you're
inexperienced
now let me talk about the data capture
now so like I kind of mentioned before
Ivy's the esp8266 boards I had one in my
front bedroom one in my back bedroom
that in the dining room I have my server
which is the Raspberry Pi and on it so
I'm running so there's a protocol called
MQTT which sins were like message queue
telemetry transport I think and it's a
it's a publish/subscribe protocol on top
of tcp/ip it's very lightweight and
micro Python has a client library for it
and there's a broker that you can
apt-get install in Raspberry Pi or any
Linux system called mosquito so I can
run a broker there and send messages
over this and then I have on my
Raspberry Pi I've got this data capture
app
and so I have a light sensor the data
capture app and I want to write five
flat files so that's all great but if
you look at kind of micro Python it
doesn't have threading and ideally you
want to use kind of event driven
programming but if anyone's done that
before it can be messy and ugly so this
is some code that's doing some been
driven programming it has callbacks all
over the place so that I would call this
callback hell it's also kind of
intermixing your data interconnections
with handling like Eric's situations and
things like that and the scheduling is
sort of like Oh something is done and
event is done I need to reschedule the
same event again to happen in five
seconds or a minute or whatever this
really low-level in Python three five
they have this thing called async await
and it kind of cleans up some of the
callback stuff but it's still a little
painful so kind of motivated from this I
created a framework called thing flow
and it's a domain-specific language for
IOT event processing runs on top of
Python 3 or micro Python and was
co-created with Rebecca Majumdar who's
at the Max Planck Institute for software
systems and so why do we create this
like I showed you in that previous
example the code can be convoluted and
there's also kind of noticed and ERDAS
ation in the Internet of Things world
for sensor api's or adapters or
transformations it's all kind of really
low-level stuff and also kind of if I'm
writing for the the esp8266 versus the
Raspberry Pi versus something else
you're typically using different
frameworks or whatever and so it would
be nice to kind of unify some of that so
I'll give you a simple example with some
of the code looks like so let's say I
want to sample a light sensor and I want
to write that value immediately to a
local file and then every 5 samples I'm
going to take the moving average of the
last 5 samples and send it off to the
cloud somewhere using mqtt so this is a
graphical representation and that's
actually what that code that page of
code you saw two slides back that's what
it does and so here's a graphical
representation of the of the thing flow
code you see I have an event scheduler
it's going to
schedule a sample of the light sensor
say every five seconds and then the data
is getting I have components to write to
a file compute a moving average and send
it to the queue so this is what the
actual code looks like so these three
lines of code do the same thing as the
page of code on the previous slide so
you can see basically it's all about
connecting things so I have a sensor and
when it connected to the file writer so
I can write it immediately and then I
have transduce is a step that can do a
stateful transformation in this case
moving average and then connect it to
the MQTT writer and finally I scheduled
this to be sampled every five seconds so
this will run every five seconds and
pretty simple so to that thing flow so
I'm using that in in my project on the
esp8266 as well as on the Raspberry Pi
so this is all the code then I had to
write once I kind of had the
infrastructure in place this is all I
needed on the on the esp8266 so what the
code does is at the top it's doing a
bunch of imports there's a sensor API I
basically took one that was written for
us very PI and ported it to to this
board and then set up some parameters I
want to connect to the Wi-Fi instantiate
the sensors and then you can see the
kind of the last three lines are really
where I basically schedule it to sample
every 60 seconds and then call the
writer which is going to send the
message over the queue and so that's all
I need and there's a special file in
micro Python called main dot pi and
anything you stick in that file every
time the system is booted up or reset it
will run that code so I just stick that
code there and then every time I run
it'll run that and do this so even if I
lose power or anything when it starts up
it'll start sending the messages over to
the queue so this is the Raspberry Pi I
won't go through all the code on that
but the basic idea is I've got two
things going on one is I get events I
get ready to get a low-level I'm getting
a socket event saying that there's data
that's coming for them mq GG broker and
I have to parse that data out and then
write the events to a file and I'm also
directly sampling from my local sensor
Thanks so that that was kind of the data
capture phase and so after running this
for six weeks I think for each roommate
about 25,000 samples of data you know
sampling once a minute and so now we can
do data analysis on all that data and
like I said I do this offline in a duper
notebook is very convenient for doing
these kinds of things and the files are
in CSV enacting is one of the dirty
secrets of Internet of Things for all
these time series databases and all this
fancy infrastructure I think a lot of
data gets stored in flat files so but it
is very convenient to work with and at
the end we want to create machine
learning models were going to send back
to run in the player okay so this is
what the data for one room and one day
kind of looked like we graph it this is
using matplotlib to graph it and the API
was a challenge now I understand how to
use it but it's kind of one day's worth
of data starting at like 9:00 p.m. and
going to a little after 10 p.m. the next
day and when you see first of all you
see the data is very noisy and you also
see there's gaps in the data so that
might be that the Wi-Fi network wasn't
working or one of my kids bumped the
raspberry pi that it happened at least a
couple times shouldn't put it on the
dining room table I guess but anyway so
there you should see a couple issues
those are issues that I think are common
for sensor data that in the real world
you need to have your your data analysis
deal with so many things you might
notice you see it was on in the evening
and then all night long it's off which I
guess you would kind of expect the
lights off people are sleeping then you
see during the day the next day you see
a couple spikes here in there that's
probably where someone comes in the room
turns on the light to do something does
whatever they're doing luckily they turn
the light off they're not wasting energy
and then so you see a spike there in the
data you see some ambient light as well
so you know during the day there's
there's light that might be coming
either from another room or from you
know from the windows shade there and
there's kind of this other area kind of
in the middle where it's up a little
higher
not clear if that's ambient light or
probably more likely you know there was
a light on elsewhere in the room so
there's a little slight things we have
to kind of infer from this data it's not
kind of quite cut and dry and what we
really want from our data analysis
before that we had to do the machine
learning is we really want to a sequence
of the light went on at this time it
went off at this time right not kind of
all this messy data so the first thing I
did is I use thing floats move the date
out a little bit so I can run things
flow in the jupiter notebook and so you
can see it got a little bit smoother
there got rid of some of the noise
there's always when you're smoothing
data there's the question of how much
smoothing do you want to do because you
might get rid of interesting artifacts
of the data if you smooth it too much
but I really want to have kind of
discrete values I want to say the light
was either zero you know or 1 and so I
think as an intermediate step I'll map
it is like zero you know there's like
one two maybe three or four levels of
the light that you can kind of see if
you kind of look at it visually so what
I did to kind of get it that way is I
ran
k-means clustering so that's a
unsupervised machine learning algorithm
where you give it a bunch of data in
this case my sample values and it and
you give it a number of groups and it's
going to try to group though the data
into those groups to minimize the
distance between the values in each
group and so I basically gave it that I
said put it in four groups and actually
seems have put it in three groups then I
can sort the groups by by the average or
by the ranges of the data and plot it
out and so this is what I get so it's
very much more discrete now I have three
discrete values zero one and two and so
if you kind of go one from that to that
now so then the last kind of data pre
machine learning step is to take this
data and map it to zero one and kind of
what I did for that is kind of looking
at the raw data and knowing what I know
about the room I think that this kind of
thing does hump in the middle I think
that's actually you know someone turning
on the light elsewhere in the room or
for
elsewhere in the house so I'll treat
that as the light being on so when I do
that then I basically map everything
from 1 or higher is on and this is what
I get and so so now we're at a point
where we have we have time series data
and we have on and off values for the
light so now let's do some machine
learning so the kind of obvious thing
would be to do a supervised machine
learning technique to create predictions
for the light so you can do regression
to predict the value of the light
or classification to classify it as
either on or off and your features might
be the time of day the time relative
that's on my Sun set because you know
obviously the amount of light you see
every day varies and all is also the
history I mean one of the things I'd
like to capture as you notice that in
the real data that you see sometimes it
lights on for a long time sometimes it's
on for a short time so we wouldn't
capture that information somehow and
your target value that is obviously
whether the light was on or off but
there's some challenges with this one is
that what's really interesting is not so
much every sample at every minute but
when the light went from on to off or
off time so then there were only even
though I had 25,000 data points for a
room in each room they were usually only
about 200 transitions over those six
weeks so that means I have a lot less
day to work with and maybe I thought I
had their thing is you know the class
sizes are different if I want to make a
prediction of the light for this it's
off right because most the time it's off
so that's the most accurate prediction
you know this is simple the dummy
classifier work really well on that but
not so interesting to achieve my
original goal and the other kind of
final issue with kind of traditional
machine learning is that it's really a
random process I'm not trying to
classify something really I'm trying to
create some random thing that look has a
similar pattern but is different every
time I do it and and so I tried a few
things I mostly got delight predicting
the light is off I know a little more
about machine learning now and I think I
can probably improve it but what I think
is a kind of another good which to this
which is what I use is called a hidden
Markov
models so it hit a Markov process is a
state mission and the state machine
where there's a outgoing transition
that's a probability associated with it
so if you look at this is one from I
took this example from Wikipedia you
have it's sunny or it's rainy
well nice so if it's sunny today there's
a 90% chance of it being sunny again 10%
chance of it being rainy the next day if
it's rainy then it's 50/50 and so this
is probably Sunnyvale not Seattle in the
rainy season but and the thing is you
know the probability is determined only
by the current state not the history
that makes it a lot simpler so in a
Markov model you're saying that if it's
sunny - if it was sunny 20 days in a row
you still have the same 90% chance that
it's gonna be sunny tomorrow it does
you know weather was 90 day you know 20
days 1 day or 50 days it doesn't matter
only the current state matters okay so a
hidden Markov model says I don't know
what the state machine looks like all I
see is the outputs and so those output
they're mathematical terminology they
call it emissions so in our case the
emissions are the light values and so
what in a machine learning world what we
want to do is say given a sequence of
emissions or light values and some
number of states that I'm going to guess
the state machine has I want to figure
out what that state machine is or some
approximation basically the closest
approximation I get and then every time
once you have that state machine is all
probability based it's a random process
I can just play it any number of times I
want and get predictions out of it and
so there's a library to do this it was
actually originally part of scikit-learn
I guess they split it off at some point
and it's called hmm learn and it has a
very similar API with fit and predict
that scikit-learn has so is easy to use
and the problem with this approach
though if you see is there it doesn't
really account for the time of day or
sunrise sunset or any of that
it's just replaying a pattern
so the approach I came up with to
address this and was basically looking
at the data I said I'll split the day
into four time periods so I have one is
overnight and up to sunrise and then
sunrise a little bit before sunset and
then to early evening and late evening
and so that's determined by a
combination sunrise sunset as well as
the you know an absolute time there 9:30
I was like usually when my kids went to
bed so I figured these are times when
the light pattern is different and I can
basically separate the data and compute
a different model for each time period
so here's kind of the training and
prediction process then so what I do
then is I have all this data that I
gathered and I fry basically for a given
room I soak build a bunch of sub
sequences for each time zone so I go I
have a particular time sample and I
figure out what zone of those four zones
it's in and then I keep on adding to my
sequence until either I hit a gap in the
data or I hit the next zone and then I
need to back up because I don't want to
kind of sometimes I might have a gap in
the data you don't know in the gap of
the data if the light stayed in the same
state or if it went on and off for
twenty times so what I do then is I
going to back up to the previous
transition and then I have some number
of transitions in a set of samples that
I kind of know everything that happened
there under all in one zone so I can
create a whole bunch of these and then I
can guess the number of states and I
guess five the reason I pick five is you
would think two because the lights on or
off but like I said I know sometimes
it's on for a short time there and
sometimes on for a long time so I figure
you need at least three and just a
safety factor I'd fought a couple more
and then so then for each zone I can I
can create a hidden Markov model and
call fit and give it all these secrets
sub sequences I created of the data
samples and thing it can do the
predictions and so then when I want to
run the predictions I visually I know a
day is 24 hours I figure out how many
minutes because I'm doing the samples at
one-minute intervals how many minutes do
I have in each zone I just say if it's
like Under
20 minutes I asked for under 20 samples
from the predict method and then it gets
it to me then I stitch them all together
and add timestamps in and I have my
predictions so this is kind of what the
predicted data look like for that front
room the the upper left is showing you a
week of data and you can see kind of
went on and off every day least once and
it has some short ones and some long
ones so it's pretty good and you can see
one room there so it's awful night
that's your kind of feature I want to
make sure I reflect in my system is I
don't want to like going on an awful lot
in the mail tonight because it's not
very realistic so that's kind of a
validation criteria and so it goes it's
on it's off all night it's on some
during the day and there and into the
evening and there you can see there's
different intervals each time so that
this is a pretty good simulation of if
someone was in the house what you would
see so now we're at replaying the lights
and what we see here is we're going we
have the Raspberry Pi and we're going to
take those machine learning models copy
them over then
so the Philips lights has a bridge that
you plug in to your Ethernet network and
it's using the ZigBee protocol to
control the lights and we don't have to
touch that part we just have to use the
REST API to do it and we just have to
say okay turn the light on turn the
light off that kind of thing and so I'll
go into it so there's a Python library
called I don't know how you pronounce
that whew or flu or fooi
but but it's a Python interface over it
so I'm talking Python optics I don't
have to deal with the rest API really
convenient so here's the pseudo code so
first thing that one thing I learned is
you want to initially have a phase where
you turn the lights on an awful lot just
to say okay did someone turn the switch
off because the one thing the lights
won't overcome it can be smartest thing
in the world but there's someone turned
the switch off at the light at the lamp
it's not going to work so you got to
figure out all that stuff so I have
initial testing phase and then it goes
into this
this daily phase and what it does so so
from now until midnight I predict how I
predict the values of the light for the
rest of the day and it and there's also
as I mentioned there's a Python API to
get to sunrise sunset for anywhere in
the solar system not just earth but you
know it's just look I just looked up the
light of the two longitude and Sunnyvale
put in that in Earth and then we're good
to go
and so I can get for that sunrise sunset
I predict the zones get all the values
for the day and then what I'm really
interested is not I don't want to say
every minute Oh turn on the light turn
on the light turn on the light but I'd
rather do is say okay I want to find the
transition so I just find all the
transitions in the data then I can build
an event list which is a timestamp a
light ID which is used by the API so the
front room or back room and then the
state of the light that I want to set it
to then I can take all the different
predictions for the different lights
merge them together and have a big event
list for the day so then I just for each
event I sleep to the event time and send
the control message and then then then
I'll grab the next event and repeat the
process and then when you're done with
that day you wait till midnight and
assuming you don't have any bugs in your
code which I did the first time I did
this it it will repeat that process
again so so some parting thoughts
lessons learned so end-to-end projects I
think they're great for learning for me
kind of having it's kind of more
motivating to work on something that has
a complete real system as opposed to
kind of a artificial homework problem
and you also kind of learn more about
how the pieces fit together and machine
learning has a lot of trial error and
error involved which I was fairly new to
it when I started this and that was one
lesson I got out of it and I think
visualization is important both for
machine learning as well as to
understand the data sensor data in the
IOT world because you know if you just
had a bunch of numbers kind of making
sense it that light data is really hard
and finally the Python ecosystem is
great for this kind of stuff and
in conclusion and if you want to talk
reach me and here's how you can reach me
and all this stuff is online thing flow
has its own page all the code if you
want to try it out all the Python
notebooks or Jupiter notebooks are
online and there's also a hardware
tutorial as well thank you so we'll get
started with Q&A here in a second is of
two quick announcements to make number
one if this is your phone I'm going to
go take it up to Boston down in a minute
number two the signup sheet for the
lightning talks is at the front desk so
if you were looking to sign up for a
lightning talk after we're done here you
should flip out and sign up at the the
registration desk
so with that didn t have any questions
off hand while I left to see if there
are new ones coming in what a lie could
you say them oh how do yes can you I
have not implemented that feature can
you repeat okay though yes the question
was how do you tell the system whether
you're home or not and I that that
feature is like when I was five thirty
in the morning and I was going to get
get ready to go to the airport I log
into machine and start up the script and
then I kill it when I get home I should
probably come up with something better
I just haven't bothered to do that yet
but I mean you could have you know
there's all kinds of work been done on
presence detection and looking for
people around you know whether people
are in the house but that's all whether
project I guess so I've got one question
so you know you the project kind of
clearly divides in two phases how much
time did you spend like you know getting
and setting up hardware versus like data
gathering and data cleaning versus like
actually doing the end parts I would say
the hardware well there is a learning
curve on the hardware because I I had
been a hobbyist in that when I was a kid
I hadn't really in got an electrical
engineering degree and then never touch
hardware again
so there was a learning curve to kind of
learn what was there and I did actually
play with the Raspberry Pi first then
learned about these other things and so
I would say that was maybe a third and
then then you add the rest the other
two-thirds was probably mostly the data
and out
and a player was you know really short
you know a couple hours at the end to
build that very good tutorial to set up
interrupts and microfibe on or for that
that I don't know because I wasn't using
interrupts for this so I was basically
pulling for the data right I mean I
don't know the thing is because you
can't really do a lot of stuff I do
think there is a capable you do
interrupts but you can't you can't do a
lot of things concurrently on that
machine because it's a limited it's not
it's not completely brain-dead because I
know we were able to do we did some work
where we put took these things and put
some accelerometers on them put it on
someone's leg we're able to sample about
20 times a second which is a bad
actually I wouldn't do video on it but
but I was but basically I wrote a
special scheduler just for this thing
the idea was the Optima to minimize the
number of wake up times so I could
optimize battery power it has some flash
on it yeah that's on the board itself I
think not on the chip so we went there
but there's one more that just came in I
have you ever tried integrating cloud
covers and input for lighting intensity
cloud cover oh I thought about it I I
guess it's one of those things
originally I had this idea that I was
going to have a another light sensor
outside my curtain or somewhere where we
did light and then I would kind of
subtract out the light from outside but
it's sort of one of those things once
you get going you feel you find oh this
solution is simpler I don't need to go
make it that complicated to do it but in
theory you could do something like that
the collisions or determining Seguros
alighted there's a light switch to I
guess two reasons one is I wasn't aware
of anything like that okay the question
was why didn't I use I'm going to detect
her at the light switch to determine
that the light was on or off and I guess
three reasons one one is that I wasn't
aware of any that would reliably work
and do that I mean then maybe they exist
but I just hadn't seen it and their
second reason is it doesn't really
capture kind of other lights maybe on in
the same room so I wanted to capture
that particularly our dining room
there's a bunch of lights in that area
and I want to capture that and it
wouldn't be as cool to be able to
interpret the sensor data I wanted to
kind of understand noisy data and see
what was like working with it so it's
certainly another option in terms of
implementing something like this worth
noting it's probably the first time in
history somebody said they wanted
noisier data yeah so any others from the
hell yeah
I have been the question what can I use
our thing flow of Arduino I think it's
what you're asking so I so I would for
that I would have to write a port of
thing flow to C or C++ and it's on my
list of things to do I haven't gotten to
you send me an email if you're really
interested maybe I'll motivate me to do
it but I haven't done it I know you can
actually run our Drina on the same
boards so alright so with that look good
and thank the speaker again thank you